y generalmente hablar de revista de
prensa con rosa pérez más de eeuu que ya
está conmigo en el estudio rosa felices
viernes para ti muy buen día vamos a
empezar hablando entonces de dos
artículos de actualidad de cara al
inicio está con 26 rosa buenos días
exacto raúl si si te parece empezamos
por la tercera este periódico de chile
de la región que hace un pequeño abc de
lo que esperar de la 26a si es rosa pues
hablamos de la tercera de chile un
artículo en colaboración con el wall
street journal es de matthew dalton y
deivid jódar y la cv 26 lo que hay que
saber sobre la conferencia de naciones
unidas sobre cambio climático del año
2021 este es el artículo de cardio
entonces vamos a ver si nos pueden
pinchar
que comenzamos pero vamos hablando
entonces este artículo rosa exacto y lo
que señala entre otras cosas de este
texto es que precisamente es importante
estar con 26 porque se van a evaluar los
compromisos que se alcanzaron en parís
porque precisamente en el acuerdo
alcanzado en la capital francesa
estableció que cada cinco años los
estados deberían a proponer nuevas
medidas y renovar los compromisos de
cara a combatir el cambio climático y
como el año pasado no se celebró esta
cumbre por razones de la crisis
sanitaria global pues este año va a
tener lugar esta revisión y que
precisamente en eeuu volvió también a
ratificar el acuerdo de parís cuando joe
biden llegó a la casa blanca porque
recordemos a donald trama había salido
de este compromiso climático durante su
mandato ahora si rozábamos con the
gardian reino unido apocalypse son un
apocalipsis cercano el artículo es
patrick windsurf este este artículo de
este periódico británico lo que hace es
centrarse en la región de medio oriente
porque recuerda allí
el aumento de la temperatura global es
más rápido que en la mayoría del resto
del planeta y además sobre todo la
región del golfo que se ha enriquecido y
ha crecido de forma exponencial gracias
a la explotación de los combustibles
fósiles particularmente del petróleo por
lo que señala los intereses de la élites
de la región van en contra de los
intereses del bien común sin embargo
señala que ya muchos países se están
comprometiendo con la transición
energética ahora vamos con un vídeo que
me llamó mucho la atención roce que
vamos a tratar aquí en revista de prensa
una campaña de la onu que muestra la
potencia a la extinción como especie
humana se llama don't you see extensión
exacto esta campaña no que ha sido muy
comentada en los medios de alrededor del
mundo lo que muestra es un dinosaurio
que irrumpe en la sede de las naciones
unidas de nueva york para dar dice un
par de elecciones a la humanidad en
términos de extinción dice yo sé un par
de cosas sobre las extinciones y aunque
parezca lógico pues no son agradables y
además se comenta pero propio provocar
la propiedad extinción es una de las
cosas más absurdas que he oído en
millones de años si te parece o digamos
un fragmento de este vídeo raúl puesto
que si rosa
al menos lo nuestro fue un meteorito
cuál es su excusa se dirigen hacia un
desastre climático y aún así cada año
los gobiernos gastan miles de millones
de dólares de fondos públicos en
financiar los combustibles fósiles
imaginen que nosotros hubiéramos gastado
cientos de miles de millones por año
financiando meteoritos gigantes es lo
que ustedes están haciendo ahora
y bien precisamente lo que acaban
argumentando este dinosaurio de
tiranosaurios rex es que con todo el
dinero que se dedica a financiar la
explotación de combustibles fósiles se
podrían hacer muchas mejores cosas para
la humanidad rosa y vamos a cerrar esta
revista de prensa con una portada que me
encantó la revista time como siempre no
haciendo sus portadas icónicas las scut
el artículo es echarlo prime en crédito
esta portada de este ilustrador bueno
sobran un poco las palabras pero vamos a
comentarla precisamente leíamos la
explicación del propio bryant del
ilustrador del autor desde el diseño que
comentaba que él tuvo la idea de que el
cambio climático era el
presente no invitado no en esta cumbre y
vemos aquí después a distintos líderes
mundiales aquí en la primera fila vemos
a la reina
isabel segunda que está pero no está
porque bueno aparte de que se ausentara
de la cumbre por temas de salud aunque
hubiera estado presente no físicamente
no sabremos tampoco hasta qué punto
hubiera influido en los acuerdos y
repercusiones se hubiera tenido esto en
la lucha contra el cambio climático por
otro lado vemos a joe biden presidente
de eeuu
ursula von der leyen de la comisión
europea grita a saber que si nos fijamos
vemos ahí su pancarta con uso y bla bla
bla que precisamente la comentábamos
ayer no lleno de titulares de la prensa
internacional en septiembre en estos
encuentros del clima que tuvieron lugar
en italia el que reprochaba a los
líderes mundiales que tuvieran promesas
vacías pero hemos querido raúl también
hacer un repaso de las portadas que a lo
largo de las últimas décadas esta
publicación time ha dedicado a la
cuestión climática y ya está en rosa
entonces esas portadas de la revista
'time' mira todas estas decisiones del
cambio de la de la copia exacto y empezó
pues no necesariamente tienen nada han
sido publicadas en distintos momentos
del año y de hecho la primera que
veíamos que tienen fecha de
1965 cuando ni tan siquiera se empezaron
a celebrar la scop que recordemos la
primera fue en 1995 y la primera está y
se refiere a los usos son malos usos del
agua luego veíamos también nuestros
sucios mares no como está también la
comparación con nuestras sucias manos
esta mítica la de preocupen se preocupen
sé mucho o por ejemplo aquí vemos gritar
sanberk elegida persona del año en 2000
ya 100 y bueno el mensaje es que todos
los días nos estamos destruyendo un poco
más como humanidad rosa gracias no es
más lunes con más revista de prensa moza
ahora con este primer invitado el día
[Música]